some folks in atlanta may need caffeine
or some other
type of drug if they find out over the
course of the next two weeks that julio
jones has been traded by the team and
here's how it goes because i saw this
play out yesterday with
he who shall not be named until segment
two
just because it's been out there
doesn't mean people really know about it
because a lot of people aren't paying
attention to it and then when that thing
happens that those of us who follow the
sport closely expected there's a lot of
people who are like what the hell is
this which was the reaction yesterday
morning when he who shall be discussed
in segment two
joined
an nfl team after nine years since he
last played in the regular season game
and i think that same dynamic applies
with julio jones shireen the falcons i
firmly believe got the word out the
monday of draft week it's not a
coincidence three different people had
the same nugget the same morning the
same week where the draft is coming and
anyone looking for a receiver in the
draft hey if you don't get the guy you
want we got somebody you could trade for
effective june 2. this noise of julio
jones is still out there june 2 is the
target date you can get a deal done
before then it just can't be done
processed paperwork wise until then
sharing i i think that
the falcons clearly want to do it the
only thing keeping it from happening is
finding a trade partner who would take
on a 15 million dollar fully guaranteed
base salary for this year and give the
falcons something in return that would
make them happy
oh no question mike and they could have
squashed this a long time ago you go
back even farther than the week of the
draft and terry fontenot basically said
yes we have salary cap problems and
sometimes you have to make moves that
you don't necessarily want to make
to to make your cap work and they're in
salary cap hell we know that they don't
have enough money right now to even sign
their draft class they're under a
million dollars under the salary cap so
they've still got to make more moves
unless they could trade julio jones so
it makes perfect sense and look calvin
ridley proved last season that he could
be a number one receiver he was that
last year with julio missing much of the
year with those hamstring problems so it
makes perfect sense for the falcons to
want to move on from julian jones mainly
for the salary cap purposes but you're
right mike it's harder to find somebody
to take on his contract and that's going
to be the difficult part of this and the
falcons frankly aren't going to get
probably what julio jones is worth
simply because of the contract
they got a second round pick for
muhammad sunu somehow
at the trade deadline in 2019 that
second round compensation has been
floated on multiple occasions over the
course of the last month peter king
floated that as a potential
price for getting the julio jones
contract and what dusted this off jeff
schultz who's covered the falcons for
years first with the atlanta journal
constitution he's now with the athletic
his story yesterday falcons may trade
julio jones so let's clear up the
misconceptions why th this isn't
something i believe that he's just
pulling out of thin air
he's got connections with the team he's
interviewed arthur blank in the past i
believe they're trying to to
dust this off again to kick this up as
we get closer to june 2 to make sure
that they've done everything in their
power to find a trade partner they want
to move on from the julio jones 15
million dollar base salary which is
guaranteed for skill injury and cap and
they want to get some sort of return and
here's the problem
and this i think is the biggest
impediment to getting this deal done
the falcons are going to be expected
to pay
some of that money we've seen it time
and again it's become a way of life
especially when you're talking about
guys with guaranteed salary teddy
bridgewater most recently 10 million
dollars would have been guaranteed to
him by the panthers panthers unloaded
him onto the broncos they're still
paying seven hey they saved three
million they didn't get much by way of
compensation via trade but they got
teddy bridgewater off the books and they
didn't have to cut him and see him walk
away to the tampa bay buccaneers and
become a backup down there as it relates
to jones
that 15 million he's getting paid one
way or the other and if the falcons
would cut him and they won't because
why pay him to not be on your team
although
if you really want to get some savings
i guess all you could do is cut him and
wait for him to sign with someone else
and they'd pay him seven or eight
million i don't know i don't know what
he would get on the open market if no
one trades for him and the falcons pick
up the rest via the offset principle
shireen but that's why this is
a delicate thing for the falcons anyone
who wants julio jones is going to say
how much of his salary are you paying
and it's a sliding scale it's you know
the more that the falcons pay
the more they it's not really a sliding
scale i don't know what it is but the
more they pay
maybe it is to julio jones the more they
can get in trade the less they're
willing to pay the less they're going to
get in trade and there's a sweet spot
there what round pick how many millions
and that's where they find a consensus
and
and and i think that's that's the
biggest issue
if they find one or more suitors and if
you get three or four teams that are
just clamoring for julio jones maybe you
get your second round picking off to pay
him anything but
for all the talk of julio jones being
available shireen have we heard of a
single team
that has made trading for julio jones a
priority
no and there's a couple reasons for that
mike i think first it is the 15 minute
we know the sour cap came down right and
there's just not a lot of teams that can
take that kind of hit on their cap right
now so that that's the first reason
second reason is some of them don't want
to give up the compensation and the
third reason is and we've talked about
this a lot mike especially on pft pm
is that there are receivers out there
everywhere now colleges i mean you go
back even to the high schools now
playing on seven on seven all the time
they just come into the nfl more ready i
remember a few years ago
many years ago i guess now when randy
moss lit the league on fire as a rookie
we're like oh my gosh a rookie's never
done this had this kind of impact on the
league it takes rookie receivers a year
it doesn't take rookie receivers a year
anymore rookie receivers come in ready
to play we saw it last year with justin
jefferson i mean these guys are ready to
play right away so teams feel like they
can go draft the receiver who's just as
good as some of the receivers that they
have now and they've shown that cd lamb
was great for the cowboys last year so
all those things i think have played a
part in this and that maybe receivers
market starts to come down like running
backs has simply because there's so many
of them out there who are so good at
this point you can go get them for a lot
cheaper than 15 million dollars
it wasn't all that long ago that randy
moss lit the league on fire only 23
years ago only a short 23 years
and and and last year justin jefferson
broke moss's team rookie receiving
yardage record and
chase claypool second round pick of the
steelers at one point became the first
rookie receiver since moss to have 10
total touchdowns in his first 10 games
so there are guys out there making a
moss-like impact and yeah the
presumption has changed and there's so
many receivers who over the course the
past few drafts have come out and
they're ready to go
why are you going to pay 15.83 million
dollars to a guy who missed
seven games
last year
and is one of the candidates for
comeback player of the year not because
he'd be coming back from sucking he's
coming back from not playing
as many games as he ordinarily would
because of injury so that's a concern as
well this guy's moving into year number
11. that is as receivers go a little
long in the tooth quarterbacks you're
just hitting your prime receivers you're
about to hit the road and i think that's
what the falcons would like to do and
again that june 2 date is so critical
they can't take the full acceleration of
his remaining signing bonus money
this year they just can't do it they've
got to split it over this year and next
year in order to make this happen but
the net result is they save millions and
create millions in cap space if
they can trade them and if they can't
they're just going to have to go forward
and what a problem to have as sims
pointed out earlier this week four
first-round picks as weapons
for matt ryan julio jones calvin ridley
hayden hurst kyle pitts what a shame for
the falcons but you know i i thought the
moment they drafted kyle pitts that that
made it clear that they want to move on
from julio jones we already
saw it coming but this isn't about
loading up your passing attack with all
these weapons this is about replacing
the capacity of julio jones with the
fourth overall pick in the draft so i i
i'm convinced they want to do it i'm far
from convinced they're going to find a
partner do you have
any thoughts as to who stands out as the
potential
next destination shireen for julio jones
well mike i think you're looking at a
team who can see julio jones is maybe
putting them over the top right i mean i
don't know that you're going to take
that on if you're
say jacksonville or houston i just don't
see a team like that committing to julio
jones when you're sort of in a rebuild
mode so it's got to be one of those
teams you know patriots 49ers ravens
kohl's chargers one of those type teams
that that really he can put you over the
top what about a team like the kansas
city chiefs i know they're up against
the cap too
but if you if you're the chiefs and
you've seen what tampa bay has done
loading up with all these weapons if you
get you yet another weapon like a julio
jones
that might put you over the top that
might be enough to put you over the top
to beat the buccaneers to win the afc
again that that they deceived like one
more thing now i don't know that the
chiefs are going to do it and they
probably wouldn't be my favorite i would
probably look more like a team like the
colts i think you could really help the
colts when you look at their receiving
core what they have i think he would be
an upgrade for them and upgrade the
other guys behind them because they
would see a lot more one-on-ones that
would probably be my favorite team to
see him go to is the colts because i
think he can make a big difference there
but a team like the chiefs i just think
he he would be good enough to put him on
the top i know he only played nine games
last year mike but he still averaged
15.1 yards of catch he can still get it
done i think he's still a number one
receiver for you if he can stay on the
field if those hamstrings are good
and with tyree kill clearly the number
one guy in kansas city all of a sudden
julio jones becomes the number two guy
gets more favorable matchups especially
with travis kelsey and remember the
chiefs tried they got in the game late
they tried to get juju smith schuster
who decided to stay with the steelers
and
smith schuster was on pftpm a few weeks
back and i think he said this elsewhere
andy reid the coach of the chiefs was
test texting photos of the lombardi
trophy as they were recruiting
juju smith schuster and julio jones
thought
he had a lombardi trophy a few years
back but ultimately tom brady and
company got in the way of that and
the
and and by the way
our draft today is inspired by the catch
that julio jones made at the sideline
that caused me to say
it's over it's done see you later
falcons are winning the super bowl
patriots are cooked and of course uh it
didn't turn out that way so great plays
by teams who ultimately didn't win their
games those
are the options for today's draft my
options my two big options for julio
jones though shireen one
speaking of tom brady
i think it would be poetic
if the patriots would end up getting
julio jones because it was back in 2011
yeah the thomas de mitroff then entering
his fourth season as general manager of
the atlanta falcons was contemplating a
major trade up in the draft with the
browns to get in position to get julio
jones he sought out advice from bill
belichick patriots coach former boss of
dimitrov
belichick said don't do it
so i just think that it would be
beautiful if belichick trades for julio
jones 10 years later and also hey
the guy who had dominated segment one of
this program
for the past three weeks we've tried to
not mention him very much unless there's
news
hell of a peace offering in green bay
yeah if you bring in julio jones and
pair him up with devante adams and at
the same time you go to aaron rodgers
and say this is the move we want to make
we need to create some cap space here's
the contract that we
would give you
that oh by the way would create the kind
of cap space give you the kind of
increase in salary that forces us to
keep you for two or three years which we
know you'll want and then we're going to
turn around and take that cap savings
from your new contract and trade for
julio jones problem solved not an easy
solution but shireen
if if the packers want to bury the
hatchet
yeah this would be a hell of a way to
bury it
oh no question mike and it makes them
better right i would like their chances
far better against the buccaneers if
they had julio jones to pair with
devonta adams they'd be tough to stop i
think and those other receivers they
have there i think it would be a great
move for the packers and i do think it
could be a peace offering perhaps if if
aaron rodgers is willing to come back
that's what we don't know is exactly
where he is is he's so dug in that he's
decided he's not going back to green bay
no matter what or if they get him julio
jones and redo his contract would he go
back that's what we don't know but if
i'm the packers i certainly would try to
take that step to make this work if
that's something that would bring him
back because
the packers as we know are far better
with aaron rodgers than they're going to
be without aaron rodgers there's no
question about that i mean you don't
lose an mvp
and all of a sudden you're the favorite
now to go back and and be in the nfc
championship game yet again and try to
take that next step i don't think that's
going to happen in jordan loves first
season as a full-time starter the way
for them to win is to make aaron rodgers
happy and if this makes aaron rodgers
happy i'm i absolutely make this move if
i'm the packers
and speaking of jordan love what better
way to completely and totally solve the
problem than to offer jordan love
to the atlanta falcons as part of the
trade package
hey
they've been talking about getting a
young quarterback here you go here's
your young quarterback here's a guy who
can can sit behind
matt ryan and then the falcons can deal
with that when is jordan love actually
going to play i'm i'm kidding about that
part
because i'm convinced the falcons want
draft pick compensation yeah i'm kidding
unless they actually do it that i'm dead
serious but but
i i i think i think if the packers
really want to fix this
with aaron rodgers if they really want
to do it
that would to me
be a significant
attempt
and gesture and and again
people aren't paying all that much
attention the average fan the casual fan
the drive-by fan that doesn't watch this
show for many reasons including that
the the
they are going to be stunned
if and when julio jones is traded
you trade him to the packers
and at the same time they announce a new
contract for aaron rodgers people are
going to lose their minds so
and and it'll be good for business i
can't i can't complain about that if it
would happen but again sharing june 2 is
the target for processing it at any
point between now and june 2 we could
hear
they have a deal that will be
put through the league office on june 2
and uh we just wait and see but but
again
weeks now
haven't heard anything no
no
reports unnamed sources unnamed anything
no no just spitballing like we've done
that's it
so i don't know who's out there and if
it's ultimately only one team
the falcons are going to have to take
what they can get and pay what they have
to pay to get jones off the
roster and it's so weird right because
in the past i mean we'd be talking about
a couple of first-round draft picks
right you look at all the trades the
cowboys made for receivers you look at
amari cooper julio jones is more
accomplished than amari cooper is and i
i realize amari cooper was younger when
he was traded than julio jones is now
and he wasn't coming off hamstring
issues but at the same time i mean
that's the compensation that we were
kind of looking at for these number one
receivers was at least
one first round draft pick but sometimes
two first round draft picks that's what
joey galloway
galloway went for is two first-round
draft picks and
roy williams so back in the day these
receivers went for way more than what
we're seeing now and if you get julio
jones
if you can make that work and you get
him for a second round pick i mean what
a steal that is right this guy can still
play he could still be a number one
receiver he's going to be even better as
a number two receiver if he goes to a
team like the packers with devante adams
he could be fantastic as that number two
receiver
randy moss was traded three times in his
career
the first time he was traded for a
first-round pick napoleon harris who had
been a failed first-round pick
and i believe a seventh-round pick that
was it
for one of the most dominant players in
league history that's all they got and
then all the raiders got when they
unloaded them after two seasons on the
patriots so they thought they were
unloading and was a fourth round pick
and then when he was fed up with new
england and they were fed up with him
the ra the patriots got a third round
pick
from the vikings and they fired him
after three weeks so it it's amazing to
think moss didn't go for a hell of a lot
more the first time around or any of the
other times but nowadays and this gets
back to
this gets back to i think the
availability of young receivers and also
the timing it's one thing for a team
during a given season
that believes it's that one player away
to make that move the same year that the
patriots gave up a second round pick for
muhammad sunu and it didn't work
the 49ers gave up a third round pick for
emmanuel sanders and it did work
he was open
with the
championship on the line the quarterback
just didn't get him the ball but he was
a huge contributor to the 49ers and he
left as a free agent after one year but
it was still worth it he he made a huge
difference for that team so
you know and and and and that's the
other side of this
even if they don't trade him
on june 2
the door is still going to be open
and julio jones is a guy that maybe they
get more sharing for him
right before the trade deadline from a
team that knows
we really would benefit from having this
guy for the stretch run
yeah sometimes we've seen that happen
mike where players get traded at the
trade deadline and they do get more form
or if a team in training camp has an
injury right at the receiver position
and says oh my gosh we're a contender
but now our number one receiver is out
for the year with the torn acl so we've
got to go get this guy he's available
let's do it let's make it work so yeah i
could see this happening even later than
june 2nd if they don't get what they
want the best case scenario for the
falcons if you said is at least have two
teams bidding for them that's what you
need you need more than one team bidding
form but at this point mike i think they
want to trade him so bad if it's even
one team
i think he's gonna go i think they're
gonna move on from him even if it's one
team and they don't get very much
compensation for him i think they're
going to move on from julio jones just
for those salary cap implications
i i've said before that the best
leverage a team has when it comes to a
possible trade is screw it we'll just
keep him
the the falcons don't have that leverage
available because no one believes that
they want to keep him it may be they
have no choice but to hang on to him to
try to get more for him later but
they're ready to move forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports